foreign
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to our
session uh building global scale
applications with managed databases and
Cloud runtimes
um I'm Harish shaikumar I lead the
global Solutions team here at Google
Cloud today along with me I have John
who's our product manager from the
databases team and then Sean as well
from a customer from Wayfair we did plan
to bring the piano and replicate
something that you saw in the keynote
today but unfortunately we couldn't fit
it over here and so you just you're not
going to have the three of us saying
we're just gonna have a talk over here
and I think I just realized that it's
Sean and John
all right cool so our agenda is pretty
simple here we're going to start with
defining what a modern application is
then we're going to talk about how we're
going to build a modern application
using Google cloud and then we're going
to have John come our customer talk
about the story on how do you build
these applications when using it in
Wayfair and then we're going to open up
the Q a after which you get to take a
survey and say how great we were so if
you have something good to say take the
survey otherwise come talk to us outside
with that let's get started so let's
start by defining what a modern app is
so
if I'm looking at people over here right
depending upon who I speak to your
definition of what a modern application
is going to be different if you're an
end user you care about hey is it
seamless does it work on all my
interfaces whether it's my phone my
laptop wherever I'm going to be using it
if you're a developer you simply want to
just focus on the business logic if it
works on my laptop I want it to work in
test pre-prod production and it needs to
be just work seamless out of it
if you're an I.T and you care about
hey how can I get it faster to
production
how can I make sure I have a simple CI
CD pipeline can I make push my code
faster make it much more agile how can I
ensure I have compliance security and if
you have a hybrid environment or
multi-cloud environment can I use my
applications over there seamlessly
across them
and then finally if you're a business
owner what you care about is hey I care
about monetization kind of launch new
features and can I build an ecosystem
outside of it
and the nature and complexity of these
applications have also changed for
example the most four important things
that I talk about if you're building an
application today is scale reliability
speed and being data driven so let's
talk about scale you just started this
application you're two people in a
garage you have one two users and
tomorrow suddenly you're this next
successful startup and you have a
million users you need to immediately be
able to scale them and then reliability
today's business is always always on so
how do I ensure I get the reliability
security and continuous availability of
these applications
and then speed if you want to quickly
kick off a new feature probably an agile
mode so that your users can immediately
get them and then finally modern
applications are very very data
sensitive so how do you store retrieve
and deliver these experiences with these
applications as well
great so when we're talking about these
kinds of Designing applications Cloud
native applications is far more Dynamic
so today when you're starting to build
this you're going to start building them
using a microservices architecture any
Cloud native applications because
tomorrow you want to just change one
feature one part of the code you don't
need to touch everything else a
microservice architecture enables you to
just focus only on that area and then
I'm going to run them on VMS you want to
package them and run them in a container
model and then when you're building
these applications you know I'm going to
go on a waterfall model take months to
build a code but you want to make sure
you have a continuous delivery of these
applications as well and gone are the
days of pre-provision you don't set up
something and just wait for a server to
just like okay it's all done but you
imagine when you keep these demands how
do I scale on demand that I keep getting
from my customers
and finally you want to avoid failures
so the resiliency of these application
is also super important so as technology
enables these attributes users are also
beginning to expect them so the expected
e-commerce application for example the
John's going to come talk about to be
intelligent and up to date with
inventory and recommendations
so honestly this is not just a technical
thing this is just part of doing
business today
so we Define what an application is we
talked about the characteristics that's
important
let's go build an application
so what do you what do you need when you
first start first you're going to pick
your choice of code I don't know you can
go all the way from C plus plus Java or
go python whatever you're going to do
and then you're going to take this code
and you're going to package them in
containers as microservices over here so
you see over here you have my
microservices like a product catalog
checkout ads recommendations
then you want to store your data so
that's a stateless application I store
my data I pick a data store database but
I want to keep everything in it
our package my applications running them
as micro Services now I need a container
orchestration so I would choose
something like kubernetes obviously I've
listed kubernetes over here but you're
welcome to go use cloud run serverless
models as well
and now you want to also connect and
secure these applications so you have a
service mesh to using outside of it and
then finally you want to make able to
manage the consumption and reuse them so
you have an API management now I know
I've oversimplified it over here there's
things that I'm not covering like day
two operations logging monitoring all
those pieces but you get the gist of it
that these are the major components that
make up as you're going and starting to
design the application
so we've defined the application we
built the application
now let's go run them
so we have two parts I'm going to talk
about over here first very simply on top
is our managed runtime environments
starting with gke
gke is Google kubernetes engine based
off open source kubernetes and for the
highest scale 15 000 nodes that you can
go and it can be used across multiple
zones and multiple upgrades as well and
you can use that to build your developer
platform as well
and second Cloud run we've got a big
shout out today in the keynote as well I
talked about you could go even build
your platform on top of gke
Cloud run that's your platform that's a
fully managed serverless platform that
you can get up to speed and just start
running and start writing code ASAP and
get deployed on it here's the cool part
once you've designed your application
put it in a container format you don't
need to decide if I'm going to put it on
gke or Cloud run
the really really great part is that
once it's in a container format and
you've standardized your application
container format you could put it on GK
today tomorrow you may decide and you
can just move it as this and move it
into Cloud run that's the cool part over
here and that's in fact I would
recommend if you're starting something
today you don't want to manage your
infrastructure at all no Ops at all you
would start with something like Cloud
run whereas if you've been invested in
the kubernetes ecosystem and you love
yaml and you've always written yaml and
you've put your entire ecosystem around
it you would use something like gke and
then we also have a feature in gke
called GK autopilot that not only
manages your control plane but also your
data plane as well
and similarly coming down to the
databases side if you see over here on
the leftmost we have Cloud SQL which is
a fully managed relational database
service for SQL Server MySQL and
postgresql
and on the rightmost side you have a
spanner that's a Ferrari right it's
Google battle tested Mission critical
database that provides unlimited scale
so spanner was actually built for our
own workload so we built this back in
2017 to run the Google's ad business and
if you saw it today in the keynote they
also talked about how they migrated
entire so Gmail now also runs on cloud
spam
and then in between is alloy DB it's our
most recent offering I think it's about
a year and it sits between it brings you
the best of both Cloud SQL as well as
spanner it's our newest postgres SQL
compatible relational database with
broad postgres SQL extension support
so
we have the applications we built it we
have our cloud runtimes and we have a
managed databases so these are all the
Lego blocks let's put them together
to build three different types of
application
Note 3 apps sorry no no two applications
are the same type so we're going to
build three separate types of app
patterns you're going to see today
starting with internal corporate
applications then we'll move to how
would a mission critical application
look like and then finally we'll stop
with an elastic applications as well
so let's take the first pattern
internal application right so let's pick
something like a corporate HR
application so now you know it's an
internal application so it's going to be
inside your corporate VPN for security
you know anybody about too much about it
and then this next what are the next
characteristics business critical versus
Mission critical so what's the
difference right Mission critical is hey
if this application goes down for even
like one microsecond or millisecond I'm
losing like billions of dollars on it
internal application is more business
clinical it's not Mission critical yeah
it's going to be a little bit of an
audience but you can still get get along
with it it's not as cost sensitive you
don't need to worry too much about like
I need to have the latest bells and
whistles associated with it and the SLA
may vary depending upon you know you
could have multiple internal
applications so what is your essay
whether it's going to be your payment
internal application or was it an HR
database
and then finally you want to make sure
you don't have less to no Ops around I I
just want to just simply have the
application to go I don't want to manage
my infrastructure at all and then we'll
talk about what build taxes which is a
really cool feature that I like on this
so if these are the characteristics I
take the Lego blocks that I talked about
how would I build such an architecture
so I would take the application because
internal apps don't receive high volumes
of traffic they could benefit using a
combination of cloud run and Cloud SQL
so I have my application packaged in
containers run them in Cloud run and
then I would have Cloud SQL as my
managed database behind it and then
because this is going to be an internal
I would put them inside a virtual
private cloud
and I would have an IAP or enter or an
identity aware proxy that can
authenticate the users now this is cool
right the IAP is what we use inside
called Beyond Cod we don't use VPN
inside Google right all our
authentication everything happens
through Beyond Corp that's the
technology getting using IAP when you
when you're able to authenticate it so
now your entire
you know private VPC contains these
internal resources and users and has a
strict security boundary enforced at the
network level as well now I know this is
again oversimplification about it but
you can see how clean and easily you can
do that for an internal architecture
now let's talk about two customers who
are actually using it let's start with
sap so I told you I'll talk about uh
build packs so sap is actually using
Cloud run they're using our source-based
deployment approach what does that mean
what it means is now you built an
application you don't need to worry
about taking a Docker file writing a
Docker file packaging in containers all
that stuff Bill packs does it for you so
you can see the actual code over here
the build packs automatically detects
the language from the source code so it
takes from the source code packages it
and then you can actually run it
straight out of the box so it's build
ship run right out of the box and not
only that inside Google a big part of
hard corporate or internal applications
are running on gke as well
and here's an external customer careport
so what they are using is they are
basically a retail customer and they're
using both gke and Cloud then and they
wanted to provide a more reliable and
high available service to the customers
so they are using Cloud run for
development of their e-commerce platform
they're using gke for their mobile
application and both of them in the back
end they're using Cloud SQL so now
they've built this new system and with
this system they're able to do about 6X
faster operating speed and they have
about average about 40 percent on
operational costs and eliminate downtime
as well
so that's
the end of pattern number one next I'd
like to call Sean to continue with
pattern two Mission critical
applications
shop
hey everyone my name is Sean I'm a
product manager at Google Cloud for
databases happy to be here today um
thanks you for coming to the session in
this afternoon I will go deeper into the
second and third app patterns some of
the more Heavy Hitters if you will the
second app that I want to talk about
today is about Mission critical apps and
these applications are a bit more
complex both in terms of the
requirements that are required but also
in terms of the way they're connected
with the other systems and if you look
at the examples we have a banking
transaction app might be kind of a
standard a standard if the number of
mission Chronicle labs are not as many
as for example internal corporate apps
but they have more
dependencies they also have a lot more
interconnected systems and also more
apis that are exposed a lot of the
mission critical apps also have higher
requirements in terms of scalability in
terms of availability and also like
things like low latency and so the the
amount of research that are required to
power these applications are a bit
higher than the first application
pattern another kind of characteristic
of mission critical apps is because
these are often used to power the
businesses they are all sometimes used
for data analytics as well so if you
have a lot of important data as part of
your application your business users are
Keen to use that data for analytics and
also for AI and ML workloads and so
these applications are not just
Standalone but they also connect to
different workloads such as analytics
machine learning both training and
serving and also some of the more recent
jmei workloads that you have seen today
to be more grounded on your Enterprise
data
um and I guess last but not least they
also require a lot of governance and
compliance standards to meet those and
so you want to make sure that the
services that are powering these type of
applications meet those standards
a typical architecture could be
something like this if you have a
mission critical app a lot of these
applications are not single region bound
they are multi-region in nature and so
you would deploy services that are that
can support multi-region applications uh
there are also sometimes have different
traffic so if you have a load balancer
up front you can actually deploy and
direct your traffic based on the
proximity of your users for each of the
data centers that we have
um the the in the middle section you'll
see that you know we recommend using gke
which is kind of our Flagship product
for our compute layer and gke you you
will distribute based on your
application workloads and wrap it around
with service mesh to man to handle the
gke fleets
in terms of the database we recommend
using a different well you can actually
use multiple different databases but for
this work to upload lodb's newest
features are really great because they
offer both high performance they also
offer four nines of availability but
also one of the cool features of iodb is
that it offers built-in analytics and
aim of capabilities and so compared to
the standard postgres lodb is up to four
times faster for transactional queries
it's up to 10 times faster as announced
yesterday for Vector queries for Jai
apps and it's up to 100 times faster for
analytical queries so if you have a ad
hoc real-time analytical upload instead
of building a separate data warehouse
and all the data pipelines you might be
able to get away with just using lab for
those ad hoc real-time smallish
analytical workloads with just alloyedb
so for Mission critical apps just to
summarize you want to make sure that
it's multi-regional that it supports
different services and of course
different workloads like analytics and
Ai and ml are supported as part of those
services
one example we'd like to share is our
fluidify which is a Canadian company for
blockchain they're running their
blockchain workloads on top of alloy DB
which supports more than 2 billion
records as they moved over from Amazon
Aurora to loudb they were able to
achieve three times faster performance
but at the same time reduce cost by 60
so you kind of see that you know
sometimes it's easy to kind of assume
that the services across the vendors are
sometimes similar but depending on the
workload and the characteristics and
their needs there's actually can be
quite drastic differences between the
different vendors
all right and the last pattern that I
like to talk about is elastic cups these
are a little bit different than the
first two in that they're not more in
terms of the amount of apps out there
this is more about the characteristics
of the app if you think about apps like
social media the number of apps out
there might not be a lot but the actual
number of users using per app can be
substantial and so the last application
is something that we characterize as
consumer facing requires five nights
availability can't go down because your
business and your customers expect that
they have to have super low latency they
have to have fast read and write
performance on the database and these
apps have to be able to scale up and
down without being with even for
unpredictable workloads and so a lot of
services that are good for these types
of applications are based on serverless
architectures because sometimes like on
holidays or on you know sports events
where you can't really predict who will
win and you just have to make sure that
your service is scale up serverless
applications several services are
probably a good candidate for these type
of applications
and sometimes the applications also
require things like you know Global
consistency because they are your
application have Global users and also
oftentimes they also require things like
end-to-end encryption because a lot of
these applications are consumer facing
you want to make sure that the data they
handle are secure
uh a sample architecture you can see
here is if your application is global by
Nature you might want to use a global
load balancer up front to be able to
write redirect traffic sometimes you
might want to use like a cache or a CDN
if you're more content heavy but on the
middle layer Cloud run is a good option
for these type of applications because
of nature that it's serverless it will
scale up as needed but also it will
scale down to zero if you have no
traffic which results in saving a lot of
cost a lot of a lot of times you know as
developers make mistakes and over
provisioning where we're kind of wasting
resources or we're under provisioning
and we have some downtime and so a
serverless in service and this and this
makes you make sure that you are good
for both scenarios in terms of the
database
um you know we recommend using spanner
because it has virtually unlimited scale
so if you have a app and suddenly
becomes a unicorn rest assured you are
covered with spanner it also offers five
lines of availability and so it's one of
one of our services at the highest level
level of availability a lot of our
customers in both gaming and financial
customers use Banner for those workloads
uh sharechat is a good example for that
they're a social media company India
um and they are able to move a lot of
their workloads to uh SharePoint
sharechat you know serves hundreds of
millions of users and they also serve
multiple types of unstructured data like
images and text and
um and uh and movies and so when their
traffic move increased by more than 500
percent a number of days spanner was
able to scale up without any change in
in the in the application code and meet
those demands and Graphics um as a
result sharechat moved more than 100
tables over to spanner and like the
example before they will they were able
to save cost by 30 percent
so to summarize
um like when to use what if you look at
kind of the chart here uh
if we just think about the compute layer
and the database layer for compute
there's really kind of two options like
Harris mentioned before if you're just
getting started you don't know how
successful your app will be and you want
to make sure you're not you know wasting
too much resources Cloud run is a good
place to start it's serverless it's
fully managed and it's really easy to
get started in terms of getting your app
up and running
uh and then later on if your app
requires more configurations more knobs
and controls you can always move those
containers to gke to get the best of
that and then there's also a autopily
version of that if you want the fully
managed version of gke
on the database side
um it's you know it looks like five
options but depending on your workload
it can be more easier to select if
you're thinking of a relational database
if you need asset transactions if you
need strong consistency for example it's
really kind of three options Cloud SQL
lodb and spanner and I kind of like to
think cloud SQL is our easiest fastest
time to Market get started kind of
database it's
probably the cheapest to get starting
with Cloud SQL as well and it offers 100
compatibility with the open source
engines like MySQL and postgres and then
if you have SQL Server you can also
migrate from like to like with Cloud SQL
and then recently we announced Cloud SQL
Enterprise Plus which offers four nines
availability so if you have if you want
to start quickly but also need a bit
more performance and availability
there's a special Cloud SQL Enterprise
Plus version that you can also take
advantage of
Nexus lodb it's our newest database that
we launched about a year ago and you
know we've in the in the keynote we've
talked a bunch about how ledb has all
the new AI features
um not only is it kind of the cool
database but it has open source
compatibility with postscripts with
postgres which is one of the most
popular or popular growing open source
databases in the world today and lodb is
four times faster in terms of
transactional queries it's up to 10
times faster for Vector queries and up
to 100 times faster for analytical
queries compared to standard postgres so
if you have a postgres workload it's
pretty much a no-brainer it should get
started with lodb
um it's uh it's one of our newest
databases and it's one of our most
popular database engines
and then if you have kind of the big
workloads you need you may need
unlimited scale uh you uh you might need
five nines of availability you uh you
want multi-master and multi-primary
um and you want like strong consistency
the only database in the world that can
do all of those is better it's a very
special database that powers all of most
of Google applications like Gmail and
YouTube and others and it processes more
than 2.75 billion requests per second
which is more than an order of magnitude
of any of our competitors can do so it's
kind of a true Flagship product for the
most demanding workloads out there
uh those three are the relational
databases if you have special needs for
a nosql database which is a good choice
for if your workloads has
um requirements for very fast rights for
example uh bigtable is a key value-wide
column database which is really
specialized for those type of workloads
things like iot or things like building
a you know a very fast write based
workloads big table is great and then if
you are building a mobile application on
the Firebase platform firestore is a
great database that integrates as part
of that it's also a document database so
if your application is based on Java or
Json a document store might be very easy
to integrate as part of that
so those are kind of our options
um again these are the building blocks
we just showed you three examples of
what you can do but there are many more
and we'll like you know there'll be q a
session attended we can help answer some
of the questions that you may have
uh and just kind of to close out you
know there are customers in every
industry for every workloads and every
users
um that we've you know we've helped
we've been happy to support uh and a lot
of these customers have been with us and
Trust as we trust Google as their Cloud
um and you know personally I think
Google cloud is probably the best place
to run the data workloads not only
because of the AI technologies that
we've innovated but because of the
battle tested nature of our services
that have empowering empowering Global
apps for a very long time and so with
that I'd like to invite John on stage to
share how Wayfair has gone with their
modernizing Journey
thanks Sean
okay got it right here okay hi everybody
my name is John Keane I'm a director of
engineering at Wayfair my teams support
a lot of the back end Services Central
product catalog pricing Services as well
as supplier back-end configuration and
Integrations on top of that the data
engine and ml engine environment for
catalog and pricing Etc
um so what I'm going to talk about today
is is a little bit about wayfair's
journey and through over the last
um well really over the last uh 18 12
months or so
the Google but really what I want to
make it clear is
when we talk about this we Wayfair uses
almost everything that uh Harish and
Sean spoke about we have a significant
Implement implementation of gke my
services run from everything from 50 to
90 ktps sub 10 milliseconds at Peak four
nines to a 12 petabyte data set in gbq
and gbt so we have a wide selection of
Google products that we use the
Partnerships that we have with Google
are very deep and they range everything
from like security and compliance to
Analytics
I can't cover all that today so what I'm
going to be talking about is the things
in blue we're going to be talking about
the the transformation from
um getting off these late large Legacy
monolith databases in SQL and a SQL and
um going through a microservice
transition as well as getting into
single purpose databases using alloy DB
Cloud SQL you know yada yada but it's
going to be mostly the blue boxes so
um
and uh it's gonna be we have about 10
minutes uh well a little bit longer than
that but about 10 minutes and it's so
it's going to be a high level overview
if you have any questions I'm happy to
answer questions at the end can go
deeper in any particular area but um but
we're going to stay pretty high level as
we go through this
so what is the problem and I think I I'd
be surprised if if
everyone in this room wasn't suffering
the similar problem you have
architecture that well intended at the
beginning it grows organically over time
and pretty soon you kind of wake up one
day and you're like oh my God what do we
have here we have to unwind this we want
to make progress and what you find is
you find that your ability to innovate
is taking longer
and you when you want to get to the new
technology platform to unwind some of
the the complicated knots of wires is
difficult
in our case we had widespread use of
shared data so we had I think large
databases order product customer
Etc large SQL Server instances that many
many teams did direct reads and writes
to so unwinding that was is a very
difficult problem and what we found is
the more we built the more complexity we
introduced and the more and the more it
took to maintain and innovate and it's
slowed Innovations so and the thing was
that we found was obviously the cost to
extend is not only an impact on compute
but also on people resources too so you
need more people to power more software
and and and the costs grow
and so
how do we approach this and so and
so as we think about it the one thing
untangling those wires was
um took a very concerted effort
um we the thing to understand is we have
these databases will have tens and tens
of thousands of database objects so all
being used by many teams across the
company and we realized through this
process that you know this is a 700
person organization with hundreds of
atomic teams and we realized through
this process that we couldn't allow for
teams to vary on their own and choose
their own path we didn't have a common
way of describing process you know one
team would say they're 20 hey John I'm
80 through my my tech transformation and
you know another team would be 50
through but they were talking about
different things you know one would be
measuring just a portion of it and such
and then we didn't even have a because
there are different common denominators
we couldn't actually determine progress
so if my boss or my boss's boss asked me
how far we were through it because we're
setting capacity aside from our business
stakeholders we couldn't really even
answer so we needed to create these
buckets to allow us to then put metrics
within each one and teams could then
describe where they were on the journey
and then also we could then measure it
and talk about progress
um
one thing we the way we approached it
was first of all we wanted to Define
ownership of all these key database
objects again 10 000 entities we used
algorithms Etc to map these and assign
ownership across our 4 000 person
organization engineering organization
and then we brought in a Federated graph
from Apollo to help us create an
abstraction layer between the clients
that we're asking for data and the the
data stores on the back end because in
the end our goal here is to get to these
individual microservices and individual
single purpose databases like Harish and
Sean talked about and be able to
leverage those patterns that we talked
about earlier
and finally the last thing is we we
partner with Google and Apollo to
actually help us train our staff because
one of the things we realized was
although people had experience with
Google cloud and people had experience
with Apollo Federated graph they didn't
actually
have the depth of knowledge that needed
to make some of the most complicated
decisions and and to architect it for
the future in the right way so we
partnered to bring in additional
training for the teams
so the before and after architecture so
when we talk about
um when we talk about moving from
unwinding these wires I'm going to talk
about a single service but keep in mind
that every single one of these teams
we're talking about hundreds of teams
and each one has many many services all
doing live reads and writes to these
shared databases what we found is no one
team actually had autonomy because
there's no clear ownership of data right
like so if if your service and one
example is our product database is
getting 242 million direct select star
from XYZ direct reads against the
database every single month so if you
are a if you are on the part data team
and you want to unwind your parts of
that that table product you can't do it
because you have all this live traffic
coming to it there's no way that you can
actually affect change and then moreover
changes Federated across the ecosystem
we have we have large large-scale
replications of every this these
databases throughout the entire
ecosystem so even if you have the
contract that you know and you know the
calls that are making directly on that
instance of it your replicated instances
maybe getting live traffic themselves so
your data contracts actually extended
and throughout the entire organization
which makes it almost impossible to make
any changes
so what we wanted to do and so our goal
was again to get to Cloud SQL spanner
every team to be able to have autonomy
within their data and their data domain
and so um and well the last thing is is
that even the services where we had
services in place they actually mirrored
the data structure underneath so the
same data contract that existed in the
table existed in the replicas also
manifested themselves in the request
response Services typically sitting up
um so so what we did was we as I
mentioned Federated graph and we brought
in Apollo and what we want to do was
create a logical abstraction between the
clients
calling the data and the data sources
and the services themselves and that's
Federated graphql is actually excellent
for that it allows you to create a
logical representation
for the schema and actually it
represented the first time in our
history where we actually had a
separation between the physical how the
data was stored at rest organized and
how clients storefront our partner home
organization partner home UI actually
requested the data and in this future
State they will not have to understand
anything about the underlying service
architecture just understand the data
that they actually need to consume
let's see what else um and so again with
this with this with these changes in
this architecture uh it allowed every
team to um own their own space of data
and have a clear line of sight and how
to improve it they actually had clear
line of sight on how to improve their
overall architecture and and drive it
now this is one service again we have
we're talking about hundreds of atomic
teams uh 700 person organization and
scaling this across that large
organization of people so that they're
all making the right decision
um is is it is the challenge that we're
undergoing right now we're we're some
distance into the journey as is uh and
we have some some wins and some losses
through it it's uh it's difficult to
organize that many people and have
everybody because you have a lot of
dependencies you know some teams may use
the same source of data and how do you
sequence those things
as we um as we kind of go through it
um that that that scale that ability to
do that in such a large amount of people
is actually where we're investing pretty
heavily
um and I I mean I guess I can't be at
this this uh this uh event without
talking about gen AI in some way some
slide having 10 AI in it but um but this
is actually an area of significant
investment for us because we believe
that this is the opportunity for us to
radically accelerate
our code migration and Tech
transformation Journey so here's the
things that we're doing
um
again we have tens of thousands of
database objects we have by the way the
10 like we've had like as those database
objects have aged some people haven't
maintained them in years and the people
who wrote them aren't no longer here so
we have to not only understand them to
build a new schema but then we also have
to to uh to scale that out across an
organization so what we're doing is
we've partnered with Google Palm to
um code bison Etc to one take embeddings
look at our Corpus of knowledge uh Wiki
Confluence I think that's that sort of
thing use embeddings for that and then
use that to understand with an llm to
understand what the SQL code is actually
saying so if you have something SP ID
well how do we abbreviate SP what does
that mean in most colloquialisms when we
use it okay it means this sort of thing
or Su supplier you know so use use
embeddings to help build that Corpus of
knowledge and generate understanding and
document for all those Legacy SQL
objects it will also use that knowledge
and understanding and training to then
build the graphql schemas for us
and then cobison will also then be able
to generate the code the backing
subgraph code on the back end and
connect up the Java python libraries to
that graphql schema that it just built
roll that out we have systems to roll
that out into production do automatic
PRS do you know coach X all that stuff
get that out
all of this is being at this stage is
being wrapped by tests on both sides and
then the next step is to move the live
traffic
the tricky part and we haven't started
we have we have this all kind of moving
forward right now we're in various
stages of each one of these steps and
getting it to production to be able to
test on an isolated subset of the tables
but for the live traffic what we'll do
is we will actually have Cody and we can
prove we can do this we'll generate a
python graphql query based upon the
select statement so select star or
select star with a join becomes a
graphql query we could push an automatic
PR to the team that owns the code and
then say here you guys can own it you
guys can you know deploy it use it
whatever but you need to be off of it by
this amount of time and we believe
through this process it will radically
accelerate our ability to get all of
that live traffic table product 242
million things a month get all of that
off the database calls directly and that
gives the team's autonomy and space to
own their own architecture and be able
to get to alloy DB spanner like those
spdbs in the back end and get out get us
out of the Legacy Microsoft SQL Server
uh large large-scale databases which are
expensive to maintain with the dated
file system and everything like that
finally the last bit is is that step
that I talked about at getting to the
data store which is using Cody and
generative AI to actually
help write all the migration scripts to
go from the Legacy table product to
whatever whatever you need so for
example table product 144 50 columns may
have I don't know 10 objects in it that
are represented in graphql schemas they
become brand or they become you know
maybe there's product there's there
could be part data you know these are
all entities within the graphql schema
we use that knowledge of what the system
built and trained on to create those
things for us and then we use that to
help build the migration scripts so that
it will generate the migration scripts
to Move It from
those 10 Fields within table product to
an alloy DB or something like that and
then wrap it all with tests so we we can
we hope and I hope I am back here next
year talking about the success of this
um but it but it actually has the
possibility to accelerate our Tech
transformation
help us with our customer stakeholders
because obviously you know business
won't sit and wait for five years for us
to do this by hand
two is it also allows us to get better
tests and document our Legacy code I
mean those are those are two big wins
even if we just did those I mean in some
of these cases it would be a huge win
for us so so when we talk about General
VI the interesting thing is said in a
bunch of sessions yesterday and and one
of the things a lot of times it seems to
resonate is you know we talk about like
search and you know image detection and
image duplicate detection those are all
you know exceptional image generation
but to me this is one of the coolest
things you know I don't know if anybody
has done these kind of things many times
in your life but having done this a
couple times
like it's you're working in the weeds
the entire time and something that can
really help you document what you have
help you migrate to the new thing
um is is really exceptional
um and it the possibilities are endless
for us in this space
um finally the last thing I'll say is
when we first moved into the cloud I
think everybody's been here we ballooned
our Cloud spin it was it went out of
control we actually we I mean this is
this is going to sound
simple silly simple but what we did was
we create transparency and
accountability we connected to the
Google billing apis we put them in
spreadsheet big visible spreadsheet
everybody saw it teams got the spend got
mapped to teams
and then we train Engineers on how to
optimize it our goal was to get the 20
optimization we actually were able to
achieve 58 optimism 58 reduction in our
spend annualized over a seven month
period happy to spend a bunch of time
talking about that but I just didn't
think that any Tech transformation I
shouldn't mention cost uh cost
efficiency because thin Ops should be
part of everyone's mindset in this room
as they as they as they enter do Cloud
work because the cloud doesn't allow for
you to think of it over the wall like we
used to way back in the day maybe I'm
dating myself but but today it demands
that every single engineer have
understanding of both operational
excellence development Excellence as
well as the cost and the financial
component
again all of this would wouldn't be
possible none this would be possible
without the great partnership Karen and
by our partnership with our with Google
helping uh bridge the gap with the
product teams as well as uh as well as
our black belt team that uh helped
assist on some of the postgres and SQL
migration I can't say enough about the
Google partnership it's really been
instrumental to this and um and that's
part of the reason why I agreed to come
here and I'm really excited about this
event
foreign